in the last video we attempted to
approximate the area under a curve by
constructing four rectangles of equal
width and using the using the left
boundary of each rectangle the function
evaluated at the left boundary to
determine the height and we came up with
an approximation what i want to do in
this video is generalize things a bit
using the exact same method but doing it
for an arbitrary function with arbitrary
boundaries and an arbitrary number of
rectangles
so let's do it so let's let me i'm going
to draw the diagram as large as i can to
make things clear
to make things as clear as possible so
that's my y-axis
and this right over here is my
is my
x-axis let me draw an arbitrary function
so let's say my function looks something
like that so that is y is equal to
f of x and let me define my boundaries
so let's say this right over here
is
x equals a
this is x equals a and this right over
here is x
this is x
equals b so this is b
and i'm going to use n rectangles
n
rectangles and i'm going to use the
function evaluated the left boundary of
the rectangle to determine its height so
for example this will be rectangle 1.
i'm going to evaluate what f of a is i'm
going to evaluate what f of a is
so this right over here is f of a
f of a and then i'm going to use that as
the height of my first rectangle the
height of my first rectangle so just
like that
so rectangle number one
looks
like this
and i'll even number it rectangle 1
looks just like that and just to have a
convention here because i'm going to
want to label each of the boundaries of
the left bound
each each of the each of the x values uh
the left boundary so we'll say a is
equal to x naught a is equal to
x naught so we could also call this
point right over here
x naught that that x value
and then we go to the next rectangle and
we could call this one right over here
this x value we'll call it x1 it's the
left boundary of the next rectangle if
we evaluate f of x1 we get this value
right over here this right over here is
f of x1
f of x1 so it tells us our height and we
want an equal width to the previous one
we'll think about what the width is
going to be in a second
so this right over here is our second
rectangle
this right over here is our second
rectangle that we're going to use to
approximate the area under the curve
that's rectangle number two let's do
rectangle number three well
rectangle number three the left boundary
we're just gonna call that x sub two
and its height
or is going to be f of x sub two
f of x sub 2 and its width is going to
be the same width as the other ones i'm
just i'm just eyeballing it right over
here so this is rectangle number three
this is rectangle number three and we're
going to continue this process all the
way all the way until we get to
rectangle number n
so this is the nth rectangle
this is the nth rectangle right over
here
the nth
rectangle and what am i going to label
this point right over here well we
already see a pattern the left boundary
of the first rectangle is x sub 0. the
left boundary of the second rectangle is
x sub 1. the left boundary of the third
rectangle is x sub 2. so the left
boundary of the nth rectangle is going
to be x sub
n
minus 1. whatever the the rectangle
number is the left boundary is x sub
that number minus 1. and this is just
based on the convention that we've
defined now the next thing that we need
to do and actually in order to actually
calculate this area is think about what
is the width
so let's call the width let's call the
width of any of these rectangles and for
the for these purposes or the purpose of
this example i'm going to assume that
it's constant although you can do these
sums where you actually vary the width
of the rectangle but then it gets a
little bit fancier so i want it equal
width so i want delta x to be equal with
and to think about what that has to be
we just think what's the total width
that we're covering well the total
distance here is going to be b minus a
b minus a and we're just going to divide
by the number of rectangles that we want
the number of sections that we want so
we want to divide by n
so if we assume this is true and then we
assume that a is equal to x naught and
then x one
is equal to x naught plus delta x x two
is equal to
x one plus delta x and we go all the way
that all the way to
x n
is equal to x n
minus 1 plus delta x then we've
essentially set up this diagram right
over here b is actually going to be
equal to
b is going to be equal to x n so this is
x n it's equal to x n minus 1 plus delta
x so now i think we've set up all of the
all of the notation and all the
conventions that actually in order to
actually calculate the area or our
approximation of the area
so our approximation approximate
area
is going to be equal to what
well it's going to be the area of the
first rectangle so let me write this
down so it's going to be rectangle 1. so
the area of rectangle one so rectangle
one
plus the area of rectangle two
plus the area of rectangle
two
plus the area of rectangle three i think
you get the point here area of rectangle
3
all the way
all the way plus all the way to
the area of rectangle n
and so what are these going to be
rectangle 1
is going to be its height which is f of
x naught or f of a either way x naught
and a are the same thing so it's f of a
times our delta x times our width our
height times our width so times
delta actually let me write as f x
naught i wanted to write f of x naught
times delta x what is our height of
rectangle two it's f of x one
times delta x
f of x one
times delta x what's our area of
rectangle 3 it's f of x 2 times delta x
and then we go all the way to our area
we're taking all the sums all the way to
rectangle n what's its area it's f of
x sub n minus 1 actually that's a
different shade of orange
let me use that same shade it is
f of x sub n minus 1 times delta x and
we're done we've written it in a very
general way but to really make us
comfortable with the various forms of
notation especially the types of
notation you might see when people are
talking about approximating areas or
sums in general i'm going to use the
traditional sigma notation
so another way we could write this as
the sum
this is equal to
the sum
the sum from and remember this is just
based on the conventions that i set up
i'll let i count which rectangle we're
in from i equals 1 to n
and then we're going to look at each
rectangle so the the first rectangle
that's rectangle 1. so it's going to be
f of it's going to be f of well if we're
in the ith rectangle then we're going to
take the left boundary is going to be x
sub i
minus 1 times
delta
times delta x and so here right over
here is a general way of considering
of of thinking about
approximating the area under a curve
using rectangles where the the height of
the rectangles are defined by the left
boundary
and this tells us it's the left boundary
and we see for each if this is if this
is the ith if this is the ith
rectangle right over here if this is
rectangle i then this right over here is
x
x sub i minus 1 and this height right
over here is f of x
x
f of x sub i minus 1. so that's all we
did right over there times delta x and
then you sum all of these from the first
rectangle all the way to the end so
hopefully that makes you a little bit
more comfortable with this notation
we're not doing anything different than
we did in this first video which was
hopefully fairly straightforward for you
we have just generalized it using a
little bit more mathy notation